por un malestar del que no tenemos
mayores detalles pero la reina hace
varios meses ha experimentado problemas
de movilidad tiene dificultades para
caminar ayer la vimos en el primer día
de las celebraciones del jubileo con
buen espíritu sonriente feliz saludando
a las miles y miles de personas que
fueron a acompañarla en este día
histórico pero la monarca ha considerado
que el viaje hasta aquí hasta la
catedral de sant pulso que ustedes ven a
mis espaldas y que es un icono de
londres y lo ha sido por una historia de
1400 años venir hasta acá subir las
escalinatas que son muchísimas y la
duración del servicio religioso era un
esfuerzo físico muy grande la monarca ya
tiene 96 años se sabe que ella ha estado
triste por no poder asistir a este
evento a esta celebración porque
recordemos que la reina es una mujer de
fe que todos los domingos va a la
iglesia así que este de los eventos
planeados del jubileo era uno de los que
más ilusión le así le hacía así que
avanza este servicio religioso sin la
presencia de la reina cuatrocientos
invitados 40 integrantes de la familia
real entre ellos políticos del primer
ministro boris johnson ha llegado con su
esposa aquí a la catedral de samples ha
sido abucheado por las polémicas en las
que ha estado involucrado en los últimos
meses del patí gate pero también han
sido invitados otros políticos del país
embajadores y trabajadores del sistema
nacional de salud en hechos